la majorité des gens s'endettent dans le
temps des fêtes comment mieux consommer
et garder la maîtrise de ses finances
avec nous pour en parler la
planificatrice financière est dépendante
110 samedi la chapelle bonsoir l'enfant
c'est vraiment un casse tête dans le
temps des fêtes de ne pas s'endetter de
ne pas se ruiner jusqu'à un certain
point
comment magazine et de façon plus
intelligente pour le temps des fêtes
mais c'est facile on va utiliser dans le
fond des mondiaux qui sont très
classiques mais qui est bon de se
rappeler planification budget dont on
parle de planification c'est sûr que
pour votre noël 2018 on est déjà en
retard mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on peut prendre des trucs déjà pour
2010 votre hauteur dans mon coffre donc
identifier la liste de tous qui a acheté
pour le temps des fêtes
évidemment donc les tâches à accomplir
pour diminuer le stress également qui
pourrait être aux que financier mais
donc on pense aux cadeaux généralement
contents ce budget des fêtes il faut
penser un plein d'autres dont les
éléments qui sont associées aux
réceptions qu'on va organiser la maison
liste donc on va on va vraiment
planifier un peu comme un plan d'action
en gestion de projet je suis la partie
terre-à-terre de l'émission donc on
identifie des tâches à faire des
responsables des échéanciers un budget
et donc encore une fois qu'on parle de
budget le pot s'arrêter exclusivement ou
qui a dole donc à tous les dépenses
connexes entourant le temps des fêtes
et quand on parle de budget ce qui est
important que les gens dans le fond
associer le mot budget à enrichissement
et non à pauvreté
donc soit un sondage d'une grande banque
canadienne qui est sorti cette semaine à
l'effet que six canadiens sur dix n'ont
pas de budget donc encore moins de
budgets des fight donc que quatre
personnes sur dix 67 titres et c'est
financièrement
al'approche défaite donc pourquoi se
priver du merveilleux outil qu'est le
budget alors un budget c'est
d'identifier ses revenus d'identifier
ses dépenses en automobiles va à la base
est très simple faire un budget même si
pour la majorité des gens c'est un peu
fastidieux mais c'est en quatre étapes
faciles
première étape pour identifier quel est
le revenu du ménage deuxième étape
combien on paye d'impôts
3ème étape quelles sont les dépenses de
base de la famille du couple du ménage
est donc tout ce qui reste c'est
discrétionnaire donc le temps des fêtes
fait partie des dépenses
discrétionnaires
quand je dis que c'est facile par budget
c'est facile de faire les étapes
oui plus difficile d'identifier les
priorités à la fin dans le
discrétionnaire parce que l'on doit
penser au temps des fêtes mais à toutes
les loisirs les vacances et idéalement
gardé de l'espace pour des paris oui
ah oui oui exactement en fait on devrait
garder de l'epargne avant de dépenser là
mais c'est ça l'objectif
quel est le meilleur moment pour faire
ses achats
c'est pas maintenant définitivement pas
en décembre je crois que tous les
experts du marketing confirmerait que
tout a été pensé pour profiter justement
un peu de la désorganisation des gens
qui ont pas planifier leur temps des
fêtes et que le doivent faire des achats
très rapide
si vous nous offrez des gros cadeau dans
le temps des fêtes il ya ils disent des
études qui qui permettent de classer les
meilleurs mois de l'année pour faire ch
à l'heure mais si on pense à des petits
cadeaux je crois qu'en établissant une
liste al avance avec les technologies
dont on dispose téléphones intelligents
on peut magasiner les soldes et acheter
les cadeaux répartis dans l'année parce
que ce que je vous disais tantôt au
niveau du budget on va être établir un
budget annuel et le défilé des familles
c'est que on était bien un budget annuel
et les liquidités peuvent varier dans
l'humour donc que des mois qui coûte
très cher décembre l'été donc le déficit
budgétaire le budget de casse un peu
comme les chefs d'entreprise pendant
leur entreprise on devrait gérer notre
nos dépenses familiales comme une micro
pme et gérer nos entrées sorties de
fonds donc dans les moyeux plus
d'entrées de liquidités on peut épargner
ou faire des achats en prévision du
temps des fêtes pour éviter que des cent
soit une source de ce traitement six
mois et donc faut être très intelligent
le faut surtout pas faire
est-ce que d'acheter en ligne ça coûte
moins cher mais ça permet certainement
de comparer
magasiner des prix dans le processus
d'achat finalement ce qui fait que
nombre des fois dépenser plus que notre
budget c'est que les émotions vont se
mélanger avec le processus d'achat
alors c'est sûr que les transactions en
ligne dans la mesure où elle nous permet
de le faire une analyse comparative un
peu plus rationnel des achats à faire
permet de faire des économies et aussi
dans le fond permet de profiter
d'aubaines des fois
et clermont connaît la popularité de
tous les événements marketing comme le
rendre fou et quels sont les pièges à
éviter de l'achat en ligne justement
faut faire attention quand même
elle va des désavantages l'office sûr
que si vous êtes en peine d'amour que
vous soyez dans un magasin ou en ligne
vous risquez de faire des mauvais choix
donc très froid demain encore là je
pense que pour bien suivre un budget on
doit détacher un peu les émotions des
achats donc avec une liste détaillée un
budget précis et le suivre mais ça
enlève le côté un peu émotif de la
chaude donc ça termine d'acheter moins
donc si vous êtes vous sentez un peu
émotif peut-être attendre au lendemain
avant de traiter votre transaction
recommandée finalement l'achat en ligne
mais définitivement je vois plus
davantage que de désavantages parce que
ça donne accès une panoplie de produits
et on peut vraiment faire des achats
sont plus rationnels et qu'il est le
grand piège à éviter les grands pièges à
éviter des problèmes à cette fin le
budget de pôle sud la première étape
c'est de le faire la deuxième c'est de
le suivre et c'est de ne pas dans le
fonds épargnés en conséquence
d'atteindre nos objectifs
quand j'étais enfin ma grand-mère
participer au panier d'épicerie aux
marchands à l'épicerie chaque chaque
mois elle m'a donné de l'argent aux
marchands pour plan penser à ces
épiceries du temps des fêtes
donc je me dois à l'avance parce que
l'action crise était beaucoup plus
difficile il ya plusieurs noms c'est un
peu de s'inspirer de ça je vous dis pas
du tout confié votre argent à un
marchand gérer vos finances et votr
richesse vous même mais épargnez
systématiquement chaque mois pour
compenser les mots les liquidités sont
plus basses excellents conseils samedi
la chapelle merci beaucoup merci bien